[Música]
muchos la consideran como una de las
mejores ciudades para vivir de todo
Estados Unidos y no solo eso la ciudad
del emblemático Golden Gate también es
considerada como una de las mejores
ciudades de todo el mundo para que los
jóvenes puedan trabajar y prosperar Y
qué queréis que os diga seguro que no
sorprende Al fin y al cabo además de
tener un sector tecnológico muy fuerte
esta ciudad está también justo al lado
de silicon Valley el mayor Hub
tecnológico de todo el planeta y además
también cuenta con un potente centro
financiero de talla mundial por eso no
puede extrañarnos que la Bahía de San
Francisco se sitúe como una de las áreas
metropolitanas más ricas y con más
millonarios del mundo de hecho tan solo
La ciudad sin contar Su zona
metropolitana tiene un pib de más de
200.000 millones de dólares lo que por
ejemplo equivale a toda la economía de
un país como Grecia no está mal con
todas estas referencias Casi casi que
podríamos llegar a pensar que San
Francisco es algo así como el cielo en
la tierra verdad pues queridos amigos
amigas de visualpolitik nada más lejos
de la realidad Si fuera así no
estaríamos haciendo este vídeo es cierto
San Francisco tiene mucho que ofrecer
pero desde hace ya unos cuantos años la
ciudad ha estado perdiendo atractivo y
ojo porque no son pocas las personas que
temen que pueda seguir el mismo camino
que en su día Detroit tomó hacia el
Abismo por eso la pregunta es Cuáles son
exactamente los problemas que castigan a
esta ciudad cómo es posible que San
Francisco parezca estar siguiendo los
mismos pasos de Detroit en este vídeo
vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas pero antes antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
creciendo por tendencias
fundado en 1776 por colonos españoles
que construyeron en la Bahía una misión
la misión de San Francisco en honor a
San Francisco de Asís el enclave comenzó
a prosperar a principios del siglo XIX
con el nombre de Yerbabuena sin embargo
cuando Estados Unidos se lo arrebató a
México en 1846 lo renombró otra vez como
San Francisco pese a todos seguía siendo
un poblado sin mucho interés aparente
hasta que apareció el oro la fiebre del
Oro hizo que la población de San
Francisco pasara de 1000 habitantes en
1848 a más de 25.000 en poco más de un
año este fue el primer gran despegue de
la ciudad el segundo se produjo con la
Segunda Guerra Mundial aquí se
estableció una de las grandes bases de
la flota del Pacífico y una enorme
Industrial ligada al suministro de
munición y equipos para la armada luego
el tercer gran despegue tuvo que ver por
supuesto con las revoluciones de las
puntocom de finales del siglo XIX y
principios del siglo XXI teniendo
silicon paso naturalmente San Francisco
se convirtió en algo así como la gran
ciudad de referencia para los inversores
ingenieros científicos emprendedores de
todo el mundo
Asimismo durante las últimas décadas San
Francisco un área metropolitana con casi
5 millones de habitantes ha sido la cuna
de grandes movimientos sociales Como por
ejemplo las protestas contra la guerra
de Vietnam los famosos hippies o la
lucha por los derechos de las minorías
Especialmente los de las personas lgtb
en otras palabras San Francisco ha sido
y sigue siendo una de las ciudades más
ricas influyentes de todo el planeta
tanto desde un punto de vista económico
como político social y cultural San
Francisco es una ciudad de locos
habitada en su mayor parte por gente
perfectamente loca Rudy arquiplin en
América notes 1891 sin embargo queridos
amigos ahora toda esta historia de
prosperidad está contra las cuerdas la
imagen de San Francisco se está
deteriorando a toda velocidad y la
pregunta es por qué qué demonios está
pasando en La loca ciudad de la Bahía
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
San Francisco la verdadera gozantitis
no es ningún secreto que en las grandes
ciudades por Norma general se cometen
bastantes más crímenes que en las
pequeñas urbes o en los entornos rurales
y desde luego San Francisco no es
diferente ni lo ha sido nunca por
ejemplo durante la fiebre del Oro entre
los años 1850 y 1856 se produjeron en la
ciudad
1400 asesinatos Incluso en 1975 en esta
misma ciudad se produjo un intento de
asesinato contra el expresidente gerald
Ford sin embargo los últimos años han
sido o mejor dicho están siendo una
locura por ejemplo entre el año 2014 y
el año 2017 los casos de robo sin
violencia se más que duplicaron hasta
rozar los 75.000 digamos que la salida
de la gran crisis del 2008 fue muy dura
luego las cosas empezaron a mejorar pero
desde el 2020 la criminalidad se ha
vuelto a disparar y no no fue por la
pandemia sino por una nueva estrategia
política la estrategia del fiscal del
distrito de San Francisco chaisa pudín
[Música]
desde su lección en 2020 budín prometió
ser más flexible Con quienes cometieran
delitos menores y no violentos es decir
básicamente se dio manga ancha y el
resultado fue un auténtico desastre de
repente los ciudadanos de San Francisco
se encontraron con un fiscal que
permitía que criminales reincidentes
volvieran a las calles sin ningún tipo
de sanción digamos que podría darse el
caso de que una persona fuera pillada in
fragante y cometiendo algún delito menor
que tuviera un historial enorme y que
sin embargo estuviera segura de que
gracias a budín no le pasaría
absolutamente nada a las pocas horas
estaría completamente libre y la
pregunta que seguro muchos os hacéis es
en qué demonios está pensando este
fiscal pues entre otras cosas en esto un
porcentaje significativo de las personas
que venden drogas en San Francisco
proceden de Honduras debemos ser
conscientes del impacto que tiene
nuestras intervenciones algunos de estos
jóvenes han sido obligados a traficar
aquí bajo pena de muerte algunos de
tienen familiares en Honduras que han
sufrido sufrirán daños si no siguen
pagando a los traficantes bowdin en una
reunión virtual del ayuntamiento de San
Francisco en 2020 digamos que la idea
era facilitar la reinserción Y de paso
aliviar la presión que sufría el sistema
penitenciario El problema es que ni
contaba con los recursos suficientes ni
la estrategia se implantó nada bien
la situación llegó a ser tan salvaje que
en 2022 se estimó que los ciudadanos de
San Francisco tenían una probabilidad de
una entre 16 que sufrir un crimen
violento o contra su propiedad y eso eso
es lo que explica noticias como esta 11
de abril de 2023 la crisis de
delincuencia en San Francisco en el
punto de mira tras el cierre de boule
Foods efectivamente amigos la crisis de
inseguridad que ha estado experimentando
la ciudad ha forzado incluso a que las
tiendas tengan que o modificar sus
horarios para evitar robos o como en el
caso de la cadena de supermercados
directamente cerrar de hecho desde su
apertura en marzo de 2022 los robos en
el establecimiento fueron tan frecuentes
que el negocio Dejó de ser rentable
claro que pese a todo la inseguridad no
ha sido el único problema que Hold Food
señaló como motivo para echar el cierre
Había otro problema tenéis alguna idea
pues atentos
[Música]
epidemias sin virus
hace ya tiempo que Estados Unidos
levantó todas las restricciones de
entrada en el país para las personas no
vacunadas contra la covid 19 desde luego
este virus ya no tiene nada que ver con
lo que fue en 2020 y 2021 Pero y si os
dijera que ahora Estados Unidos está
sufriendo su propia epidemia vale Ya sé
lo que estaréis pensando por favor
Enrique no más enfermedades
dadnos un respiro tranquilos que esta
vez nos vamos a hablar de ningún virus
lo que está flotando a todo el país y
San Francisco de forma especial es una
epidemia muy pero que muy particular la
de las drogas y más concretamente la de
los opioides Y es que veréis como seguro
que ya muchos sabéis los opioides son
drogas derivadas de la planta del opio
muchas de ellas se usan como fármacos la
oxicodona o la morfina son los ejemplos
más claros ambas se usan para tratar
todo tipo de dolores Pero por desgracia
también han caído en el mercado negro y
se han convertido en la causa de grandes
adicciones pero no no son ni la
oxicodona ni la morfina las que están
creando el caos sino otra droga de la
que muchos Seguro seguro que ya habéis
oído hablar en los últimos tiempos el
fentanilo
desarrollado en 1959 E introducido en
Estados Unidos en el 60 como un
anestésico intravenoso y el fentanilo ha
sido un fármaco usado habitualmente por
médicos para aliviar dolores después de
cirugías o derivados de patologías como
el cáncer sin embargo el auge en la
calle de esta droga 50 veces más potente
que la heroína y 100 veces más potente
que la morfina no llegó hasta el año
2011 cuando siendo una opción
infinitamente más barata que la heroína
empezó a ganar cuota de Mercado El
problema es que esta sustancia también
es mucho más mortal para que os hagáis
una idea en los dos primeros años en el
mercado Negro entre 2011 y 2012 el
fentanilo que usó la muerte por
sobredosis de 5.200 personas en 2022
según datos del cdc unas 70.000 personas
fueron víctimas mortales de esta droga
que es mezclada habitualmente con otras
como la metanfetamina Sí sí lo habéis
oído bien 70.000 víctimas mortales
queridos amigos el abuso de los opioides
y en especial del fentanilo ha provocado
una enorme crisis con dec casi decenas
de miles de víctimas y un impacto
económico multimillonario un informe del
Congreso dice que la crisis de los
opiáceos le costará Estados Unidos casi
1,5 millones de dólares en 2020 tan solo
en 2020 un 7% del pib de locos por eso
la administración ha empezado a tomar
cartas en el asunto
Y es que veréis esta droga no se produce
dentro del país sino que es fabricada
con químicos llegados desde china por
cárteles mexicanos que luego la
introducen en Estados Unidos estamos
hablando sobre todo del Cártel de
Sinaloa Pues bien la administración
vaivén Ya le ha pedido a China que sea
más estricta y que tenga más control
sobre sus exportaciones de químicos al
tiempo que está trabajando para
incrementar la cooperación con México
ahora bien Cómo creéis que han
reaccionado ambos países Pues por ahora
china se ha comprometido a ayudar a
Estados Unidos sin embargo no parece
estar cumpliendo Lo prometido de hecho
la mayoría de los analistas están
seguros de que china está interesada en
que esta epidemia no se termine y México
pues habló seguro que está cumpliendo
verdad pues desgraciadamente parece que
prefiere echar balones fuera fijaos el
presidente mexicano achaca la crisis del
fentanilo en Estados Unidos a la falta
de abrazos entre las familias Andrés
Manuel López Obrador achaca la falta de
abrazos las 70.000 muertes anuales por
sobredosis atribuidas al opioidi
sintético las situaciones devastadora en
todo Estados Unidos y particularmente en
San Francisco La perla de la Bahía es
una de las ciudades más afectadas fijaos
Y sí como seguramente os estáis
imaginando el fentanilo es el mayor
responsable de esta tragedia de hecho
para ser exactos esta sustancia fue la
culpable de siete de cada 10 víctimas
mortales y desde luego las cosas no
están mejorando las muertes por
sobredosis en San Francisco alcanzan las
200 en tres meses una auténtica
vergüenza el aumento del 41% se produce
cuando la ciudad ha cerrado un centro de
asistencia que disponía de narcan y
permitía el consumo supervisado de
drogas de hecho recordáis el
supermercado que cerró en San Francisco
por la inseguridad Pues en septiembre
del 2022 se encontraron a una persona
fallecida por fentanilo y metanfetamina
En los cuartos de baño y luego la
entrada estaba siempre atestada de
personas consumiendo estas sustancias
así que ya lo veis tanto la inseguridad
como los narcóticos están haciendo que
la que ha sido calificada por muchos
como la ciudad más bonita de Estados
Unidos se esté sumiendo en un oscuro
Abismo pero penséis que hemos terminado
pues no nada de eso atentos
[Música]
El Éxodo urbano
Si vivís en alguna ciudad grande como
Madrid Chicago Roma o París o os habréis
dado cuenta de que los alquileres están
por las nubes sin embargo según el foro
económico mundial ninguna de estas
cuatro ciudades por ejemplo se encuentra
entre las ciudades más caras en las que
vivir pero os sabéis cuál si está en el
top ten efectivamente Frisco San
Francisco y os preguntaréis esto a qué
se debe pues sobre todo a un problema en
concreto Los Altos costes de las
viviendas por supuesto Los Altos precios
de las viviendas no vienen de la nada
Por lo general se producen porque la
oferta es mucho menor que la demanda Y
este es sin duda el caso de San
Francisco por ejemplo la ciudad de
Austin en Texas que tiene una población
similar a San Francisco ha construido
133 mil viviendas nuevas desde el año
2010 sabéis cuántas se han construido en
la ciudad de la Bahía apenas
37.500 como os podéis imaginar esto ha
hecho que tanto los alquileres como los
precios de las casas se disparen y la
situación ha llegado a tal punto que ya
está afectando al tejido productivo de
la ciudad
de hecho en San Francisco se ha
construido solamente una casa por cada
ocho trabajos nuevos en la última década
y con las oficinas ha ocurrido tres
cuartas partes de lo mismo y si creíais
que la situación no podía empeorar la
pandemia de la covid-19 ha puesto patas
arriba a la economía de la ciudad Por
qué pues por una simple razón el
teletrabajo San Francisco duplica con
crecer su estimación de trabajo
permanente a distancia efectivamente Los
Altos precios de las oficinas han hecho
que el teletrabajo se haya puesto de
moda en San Francisco desde el año 2020
de hecho algunas estimaciones apuntan a
que ahora mismo en torno al 25% de las
oficinas de la ciudad podrían estar
vacías Y sabéis a qué está dando lugar
esto Pues por un lado que las calles
estén cada vez más vacías lo que está
haciendo que algunas tiendas y
restaurantes que vivían de los
trabajadores de las oficinas estén
cerrando por otro lado imaginaos que de
repente os ofrecen trabajar os
quedaríais en una ciudad donde el
alquiler consume casi todos vuestros
ingresos puede que alguno si lo
hicierais por ciertos motivos pero
seguro seguro que muchos os iríais a
vivir a lugares más baratos Pues bien
justo Esto es lo que también está
pasando en San Francisco muchos
profesionales están yendo a vivir a
otras ciudades e incluso a otros estados
pero no solo los trabajadores están
intentando irse muchas empresas también
están barajando esta misma idea y es que
veréis al teletrabajo y los altos costes
de los alquileres los segundos más caros
de todo el país se le une también un
factor importante para las empresas la
presión fiscal el 59% de los ejecutivos
de las Industrias tecnológicas de San
Francisco consideran que los impuestos y
regulaciones tanto de la ciudad como del
Estado son excesivos pese a lo cual no
dejan de aumentar
vamos que San Francisco también se está
enfrentando a un creciente Éxodo de
personas y empresas es algo todavía muy
incipiente pero el riesgo está sobre la
mesa y eso es lo que explica noticias
como esta Este es el Plan de San
Francisco para acabar con la burocracia
y construir 82.000 viviendas inseguridad
drogas y altos costes de la vida parecen
estar haciendo que San Francisco se una
a una lista de viejas glorias como
Detroit o San José por supuesto no van a
bajar los brazos Tan pronto el gobierno
de la ciudad ya ha conseguido el apoyo
del gobernador de California Gabi newson
para desplegar una fuerza antidroga
además los vecinos de San Francisco ya
han sustituido al desastroso budín por
Brook jenkins una nueva fiscal del
distrito mucho más estricta y no solo
eso también cuentan con el apoyo de la
Administración biden que ha presentado
la estrategia nacional para el control
de drogas pero sea como sea si algo
parece claro es que San Francisco no
está atravesando sus mejores momentos y
la pregunta es crees que fiscal logrará
reducir la inseguridad de la ciudad de
qué forma podría hacer frente San
Francisco a la epidemia del fentanilo
tendría que intervenir el Gobierno
Federal puedes dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios como siempre no
olvidéis Que aquí en visualpolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos Todas las semanas
así que suscribíos a este canal y darle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones si este
vídeo te ha resultado interesante Dale
al botón de like y como siempre nos
vemos en el próximo
[Música]